Chers amis démocrates, nous sommes ici
au Jardin de la gare,
sur la commune nouvelle de Condé-sur-Vire,
dans le département de la Manche.
Ce lieu, nous l'avons entièrement rénové
et entièrement réaménagé.
Il avait été pendant trop longtemps
désaffecté et nous avons décidé d'en faire
à la fois un lieu de renaturation
mais également un lieu d'attractivité
avec un ensemble de services
qu'on peut offrir à la population
et notamment en termes sportifs,
en termes de rencontres,
que ce soit pour les petits
ou pour les grands.
Et de façon à donner tout son sens
à ce projet,
nous avons également réalisé
une voie verte qui se trouve derrière moi
et qui permet de relier cet ensemble
réaménagé
aux bords de Vire avec l'installation
notamment d'une passerelle.
Et puis, vous aurez remarqué également
que juste derrière moi se trouve
ce bâtiment de l'ancienne
gare que nous avons aussi revalorisé
pour l'association du vélo-rail,
mais également pour le centre aéré.
Tout cela fait un ensemble cohérent pour
un investissement d'environ 1 200 000€,
mais pour un reste à charge
pour la commune de Condé-sur-Vire
d'environ 30% du montant total.